قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائلي دانييل
هكاري ان 24 جنديا وضابطا سقطوا دفاعا عن
امن اسرائيل واضاف ها جاري في اجازه
اليومي ان اطلاق فلسطينيين قذيفه ار بي جي
تسببت على الارجح في انفجار ادى لانهيار
مبنى وقتل من فيه من الجنود
الاسرائيليين اود ان اطلعكم على حادثه
صعبه للغايه حدثت بالامس خلال العمليه
التي جرت في وسط قطاع غزه قتل 21 جنديا
احتياطيا وكانت القوات تعمل في منطقه تقع
بين البلدات الاسرائيليه وغزه بالقرب من
بلده كيسوفيم
وكانت القوات تزيل المباني والبنيه
الاساسيه الارهابيه في المنطقه على بعد
نحو 600 متر من الحدود وتهدف المهمه الى
توفير الظروف الامنيه اللازمه للسماح
لسكان جنوب اسرائيل بالعوده الى منازلهم
وعلى حد علمنا في هذه المرحله يبدو انه
حوالي الساعه الرابعه بعد الظهر اطلق
الارهابيون صاروخ ار بي جي باتجاه دبابه
كانت تؤمن القوه وتزامن ذلك مع انفجار ادى
الى انهيار مبنيين من طبقين فيما كانت
اغلب القوى بداخلهما وبالقرب منهما وما
زلنا نحقق في تفاصيل الحادث وسبب
الانفجار